[موسيقى]
رغم ما يشهده المسجد النبوي من توسعات على
مر التاريخ الا ان اساطينه ثمانيه بقيت
شاهده حتى وقتنا الحالي ولكل منها قصه
تاريخيه بالمسجد وتسمى باعمده الاساطير اذ
كانت من جذوع النخل قديما واشتهرت منها
سته اساطير وهي تقع بين جنبات الروضه
الشريفه وارتبطت باحداث السيره النبويه
دعايه الاسطوانات كانت اعمده جذوع نخل ثم
في عهد عثمان بن عفان اصبحت من الحجاره
المنقوشه ومحشوه بالرصاص ثم بعد ذلك في
عهد الوليد وعمر بن عبد العزيز تغيرت
الوضع استعمل الرخام الى عهد الملك فهد
رحمه الله كان في هناك ترميمات ويعاد كل
فتره لعمليه الصيانه وبالنسبه ضرب البويات
بالنسبه للاسطوانه منذ اربعه عشر قردا لا
تزال اساطير المسجد النبوي تحمل الماء
التي سميت بها في العهد النبوي وتتزين
اليوم باللون الذهبي واصط لوحه خضراء ومن
اهم هذه الاساطير التي ارتبط موضوعها
بتاريخ وسيله النبي الاسطوانه المخللقه
والتوبه والمحرز الاسطوانه واسطوانه
المخللقه وهي خلف المحراب الموجوده الان
النبوي الشريف وسميت بالمخلقه لانه كانوا
تطيب بطيب الخلوق وهو افضل انواع الطب في
زمن عمر بن عبد العزيز اسطوانه السرير كان
يوضع له سرير عليه الصلاه والسلام اذا
اراد الاعتكاف بالمسجد اسطوانه الحرس او
اسطوانه علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
اللي كانوا يحرص الرسول عليه الصلاه
والسلام
[موسيقى]
اسطوانه الوفود كان يستقبل عند الوفود
اسطوانه ابي لبابه
اللي كان يربط وربط فيها ابو لبابه نفسه
ثم اسطوانه عائشه ويقال اول بدايه تحول
القبله صلى عنده عليه الصلاه والسلام لمده
ثلاثه اشهر ثم التقدم محراب النبوي
الموجود في الروضه حاليا تلقى الاساطير
القابعه بالروضه الشريفه عنايه واهتماما
كبيرا من قبل رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اذ شهدت
عمليات ترميم وتحسين مستمره من المسجد
النبوي سلطان السلمي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات